un gioco in particolare mi avete chiesto
negli ultimi due anni credo avevo fatto
la demo secoli fa 3 2 1 the wardrobe è
stato fatto da dei ragazzi italiani
avevo già fatto la demo no a partita
allora vi dico la verità la storia di
due giovani ragazzi legati nell'amicizia
nel destino senegal ma che è ronald
schemi come accadeva spesso erano usciti
per fare un pic nic e trascorrere la
giornata nelle campagne vicine ad un
tratto ronald tiro fuori dal suo cestino
un paio di piccole prugni n porse una
all'amico che schifo le prugne strappare
leziosa deliziosamente murgia le una
prugna ragazzi
carla bruni a cosa donatore come lo slow
motion renda tutto più epico no non è il
caso o il ragazzo rimase perù
riabbracciato ai fili d'erba quando ad
un tratto accade qualcosa una nuova
fiammella di riditorino installata
chissà
il segreto
è spaccato all'interno dell'armadio di
ronald perché degli assi su di lui per
il resto dei suoi giorni
o almeno fino ad oggi giorno in cui ha
inizio la nostra storia ma che figata è
bellissimo è riuscito skinny quindi
schiava skinny 3 il protagonista ben
segnato
perdonami ma non sono riuscito a dormire
granché stanotte sei veramente sicuro di
volergli parlare non ho altra scelta
secondo me libera un infarto e finirete
entrambi a farvi compagnia nell'armadio
spero proprio di no posso già interagire
hai visto ronald quando smetterà di
mangiare quella roba scappo in capo in
bagno tutta questa agitazione mi ha
allentato la vescica
non ce l'hai la vescica quale problema
che figata incredibile non molto tempo
dopo inizia da qui allora porta
l'animaletto del furgone
io intanto preparo gli scatoloni in
salotto yahoo
mezz'ora dopo venne mi ci voleva proprio
una doccia non so che doccia ti sei
fatto zio ma non credo stanzia
proseguiamo insieme al piano di sotto
allora io intanto avverto la signora ho
paura che ci vorrà più tempo del
previsto per finire questo maledetto
trasloco trasloco in tutto questo non
devo farmi vedere quindi devo scappare
da qualche parte e ora chi doveva ai
ragazzi non ho capito se devo andare di
là però ci sono quelli che stanno
traslocando oppure se devo continuare a
fare cose di qua proprio nel frattempo
per ed ora ogni saggia decisione deve
sapere che l'orso è convinto di essere
sposato con la paperella scusa che è che
cos'è turisti sto vedendo ma cos'è
ragazzi filippo comunque amo e lo stile
di disegno che altro gioco ora che il
rischo di evitare le pillole a ho preso
le pillole perfetto ma questo è il mio
mentario l'inventario è gabbia toracica
va bene
per adesso nella pirite delle pillole
perfetto ragazze giocano ma vai sul
trono ma grazie per esserti preoccupato
della mia regolarità intestinale ego
skin tu non ce l'hai neanche l'intestino
non è vero sono semplicemente estetico
va bè ragazzi a questo punto proviamo a
uscire visto che ancora dov'è finito il
mio armadio non posso allontanarmi dal
mio armadio è una questione di vita o di
morte
un trapano sorprendere il trapano
perfetto jerry song pesci vai vedere se
c'è l'armadio da qualche parte cosa sto
vedendo qui
quanta roba se il padre del ritratto
sospetto il quadro dello slider man che
si muove da solo tra l'altro non posso e
soprattutto non voglio toccarlo scusa
frate non volevo e pieno di riferimenti
acqua cos'e tifato i storico è pieno di
roba finissimo una dentiera premia
tempie razzi a cosa mi serve una
dentiera lobotomizzati va bene sanremo
frank robert spegnere vabbè
scendiamo a questo punto volevo se ne
parla quei due sono ancora lì spesso e
come faccio uscire di qua scusatemi la
finestra non va dalle scale non va o lo
scarico di riscatto scaricati
non è vero non è vero sono anni che può
farlo in un videogioco del successo
veramente
non ci creò rega da quando aperto il
canale che tentò di scaricarmi in un
cesso in un videogioco non ha mai
funzionato per una volta funzionato c'è
bot
let's go amici miei let's go salve
giorno coccodrillo posso parlare con
coccodrillo lo so sto vedendo salve un
mucchietto d'ossa ti prego non mangiarvi
peso deve mangiare non c'è neanche la
carne
mi sembra proprio un tipo apposta il
proprio un tipo a posto sai veramente
sono appena evaso da un carcere di
massima sicurezza per rettili va bene
però finito dentro dopo aver sgozzato
con una lisca di pesce i miei vicini
facevano troppo rumore non riuscivo a
dormire
prometto che non farò mai nulla per
farti arrabbiare non hai una misurazione
della cera va tutto bene ho un dolore
insopportabile a un dente
dove è finito qualcosa dentro a citare
sti un'occhiata
ok va bene
in effetti c'è qualcosa incastrato ma
non credo che riuscirei a toglierlo a
mani nude ci penso io si perpetravano
trapano ti ricordo che il trapano e
senza con questo tipo ma anche palle o
due voi che trovi la punta di un trapano
ma che ne so o dell'acqua in mano ma non
è la mano e adesso ho solo un principio
di reumatismi uscire già c'era una
stanza segreta non avevo vista salve
dove che siamo qua e là ma do quanta
roba mi versa qualcosa non so bel
posticino lei e tutankhamon eravate
forse parenti ma lei è tutankhamon
eravate parenti hanno ricevuto niente
posso dirgli ma se si nota una certa
somiglianza
forse il naso che poi comunque so io
quando la gente mi parla e se uguale
boccale posso va bene allora andiamocene
va bene così dopo quasi per scontato che
col boca e io possa raccogliere sta roba
che non potevi raccogliere con le mani
perché non hai le mani alla salute acqua
di fogna non so cosa possa mai servirmi
dell'acqua di fogna ma va bene andiamo
su hummer agavi di andar accogliere
qualsiasi cosa senza tetto ha come unica
riuscirei a svegliarlo un grosso
energumeno addormentato mi sbarra la
strada
chissà perché ma sto avendo uno strano
dice josé nord l'acs va bene andiamo
avanti ragazzi non è tanto jp talmente
pieno di roba che puoi fare un miliardo
di coop fai quello che vuoi azione
cosa ho fatto esplodere va beh non lo
scopriamo dopo
cosa stavi a parte il fatto che ci sono
le pagine dello slang hermes è un cieco
questo mi scusi signore possa
disturbarla un attimo giovanotto non
vedi mi fanno molto impegnato 6 porta
tengo ditemi che è uno scherzo dei tubi
metallici per terra ne ho preso uno raga
non so cosa vi posso servire male anche
di sopra volendo
dovrei dovrei essere ecco dove conduceva
quella porta in tutti questi anni
nessuno si era mai degnato di forzarla
certo non avrei mai aperto questa porta
di casa tua va bene vanta roma cia in
casa gesù quanta certo che qualcuno
potrebbe anche dare una pulita di tanto
in tanto e bene finché stai nell'armadio
è un po difficile amico mio bromo e
questo come ci è finito qui dentro ho
trovato un registratore e nelle altre
stanze ai controlla mai quelli che
devono traslocare dove che sono finiti
ci sono più se sono andati prima di
andare di qua eccoli sta facendo pausa
pranzo va bene ma a parte questo ragazzi
col registratore che ci devo fare la
sveglia sveglia premio perfetto la
sveglia credo penso che non lo so che
serva per svegliare lowes norma che ci
prova raga perché non ne ho idea in
realtà
sveglia ti ricordo che la sveglia è
rotta questo tuo deficit d'attenzione
talvolta è particolarmente irritante non
è la prima volta che me la dicono sta
cosa anche la mia maestra alle
elementari me lo diceva sempre unito
l'intruglio con le medicine quindi
serviva per limitano vado alla soluzione
ai tuoi problemi
devo fare devi solo aprire la bocca
parla pure a fa bene a correre ma non
sapere chi è che parlasse cio busato
oggetti a caso
ma no non fai come i pokémon
[Musica]
bene mi sento 31 con forza nelle mani
sfida cavolo che figuraccia con che
faccia a chiedere a mister muscolo di
grano
mi sentii zio mi invitarono a svitare il
coso 6 voglia non sempre secondo me non
sei così forte ma cosa stai dicendo
non lo vedi che solo fortissimo almeno
sembra mettimi alla prova allora qui
nella camera accanto c'è un letto sono
sicuro che non riuscireste a svitare uno
dei pomelli sono un gioco da ragazzi ok
bene l'abbiamo abbindolato sul serio
anche il pomello che non sto vedendo
regalo addirittura l'animazione lo
svitato ha svitato un pomello che sembra
buona palla da tennis ma che ti serve
non funzionerà ci ho provato sarebbe
stato troppo non capisco o doveva
sciogliere il pomello sì c'è perché a me
sarebbe venuto in mente di sciogliere il
pomello se nuova ci avevo pensato 20
volte guarda a cagare va trapano vai vai
a sfidarli la faccia con l'uomo che cesc
vitali qualcosa
let's go arriviamo farsi spalanca le
fauci e non fare scherzi
guarda come si caga addosso guardalo
guardare gli abbiamo trapanato la faccia
almeno quello è una vera e propria
liberazione
un po come quando sono evaso di prigione
non riesco a capire se parli sul serio o
mi stai solo trullando clamorosamente
non lo scopriremo mai
che sorpresa ingranaggi ciacciarelli gli
ingranaggi dentro la bocca quest'uomo
della mia sveglia tra l'altro agli
ingranaggi come il cui ci son finiti lì
ma non importa o la sveglia posso far
passare il bar boom ci ho messo un'ora e
mezza malesia
eccoci qua tiene amico mi chiamo come se
fosse una bomba non potevi urlare no
questo stop e dello zio
[Musica]
e addirittura l'open non potevi urlare
ce l'avremmo fatto a un'ora fa
se solo avessi urlato però vabbè andiamo
quindi ragazzi questo era il primissimo
episodio di the world
però mi piace perché come nuova serie ho
intenzione di finirla quindi 100.000
likers uno scherzo mettete like so se
volete però io lo faccio comunque quindi
come sentimento mi piace anche a vari
social economy notizia non è solo
rischiate e noi ci vediamo
beh ragazzi
[Musica]